you know on the 7-footer that stay with
a lot of anger and you know people don't
have that vision of me crying do the
aliens know that we exist
we took my my best friend is an alien if
you just want to believe the easy answer
to make you feel better
most people do I'm going to be a big man
Rudy Gobert he was wildly made fun of on
social media when he shed some tears
after not making the all-star game but
then the end of the season breaking the
all-time single-season dunk record so
now we're off to SWAT let's unique to
learn more about it you coordinated very
well for this shoot so on Instagram you
commented on a photo or video of JoEllen
beads saying that he was the best
offensive player in the league and the
most unstoppable player in the league
you put laughing emojis why was that
funny
gloves accent that's right was many yeah
had nothing to do with what he said yeah
what he says I mean it's almost like
every interview is try to say that it's
the best offensive player in the league
you don't need to say it every interview
you know people are gonna look at the
stats and look at the numbers and and
judge for themselves for you what how do
you judge you see the guy to mix is to
better the in fact I mean I think it's a
mix of bullets I would say it's the
impact the impact that you have depends
yeah so yeah I think I am so every show
I have a segment where I have the guest
take me to that moment that time that
person whatever the case may be ready
okay okay take me to how you picked your
jersey number 27 I've got drafted 27 I
was a little frustrated to be exact it's
so low so I thought it was
a great reminder you know to myself and
to everyone that kind of didn't draft me
do you know everyone that was drafted
before you all of them
let's punish these guys that's gonna
damn it but you've stolen at the pull
apart-er
I'm gonna forget if you want take me to
a walk through the mountains around your
home yeah when I'm when I move here you
know I'm ready the mountains were a big
part of a big reason why I chose this
home you know he was very private
I really like the views you know and uh
and I like to go hiking so when you said
you got drafted to Utah you're like what
is your top did you envision this being
Utah don't everybody be the robot things
like that here
I'll never skip all that maybe snowball
snowball snowball
I did snow balls before yes with
snowboard no ball fighting these mangry
is that bad no I just didn't hear it
snowboard snowboard it's no boy that's
what you say that's exactly like
snowboard in the motion
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
where did NBA defense go
you know it's like the lot of animals
are going instinct it's kind of the same
you know I just think people are more
focusing on individual performance more
than winning you're a defensive minded
guys I think that you always kind of
lean towards players that play good
defense
who should be the MVP I'm a defensive
man guy Bama I'm a winning minded guy
you know I like I like the guys that
that do all the other things I help your
team win we focus too much on the on the
points and you know not necessarily on
the guy that created the action or the
guy that said it's the stream we should
win MVP if I had the vote our bikinis
just because apparently more defense and
the impact that you have trash on the
court a little bit
did you talked to gallus I try to learn
some bad words in Greek Monica which is
I'm gonna say and then there's a way to
say your neck you off what I keep
enemies these EXO so what every free
throws of EXO EXO do you like first time
first time you give me the look you
don't work well so how often do you
think about this past all-star I don't
write I want to say that think about it
what you feel as though you should have
been an officer I mean I understand
you're not thinking about it every day
but that was a moment for you like a
very frustrating moment for you you know
it's human nature to be disappointed
I'll be frustrating but it's always you
know how you bounce back and how you
react to that
well you surprised at the reactions to
that I'm not really surprised sometimes
you you cry we don't even know why and
this is because of the perception people
have of me you know on the 7-footer that
fair with a lot of anger and no part
have that vision of me playing love you
oh my goodness
this is why you should get a dog yeah
it's really cool like every we've passed
knows that you just broke the dog record
I don't know if it's like that in every
city that everything he knew the exact
number it's great no you really have
some great fans in the vini embrace who
we are so I'm curious because you were
somebody who had a lot of ways and
bodies different identities right like
you're French you're black I'm kind of
mix up everything yeah how I mean how do
you identify as a human being you know
as a citizen of Earth I would say you
know my dad's black my mom is white and
I'm very proud I'm a black fan I'm very
proud of my wife and I'm proud of Who I
am you had a tweet where you were
defending the places that we're called
[ __ ] countries do you remember the
seat okay
so you said do you know what it means to
have dreams to actually have to work for
something does the fact that I left
France to come taste my dream here make
France a [ __ ] or does not just apply
to African countries
like us you know the big countries maybe
the top of the world countries we
actually don't take a lot of resources
for them we don't allow them to download
so then we we call them [ __ ] all
countries but let them develop let them
have their own you know leaders and then
takes a different story one day I was
running I was running here that's so
snake how bigger this name that's a big
buddies just like scared easily - I was
careless I don't care all these spiders
I don't like them but I'm not scared of
them
do you like let out a little scream when
you see insects you jump when I saw that
snake it's just funny that someone so
tall will be scared of something so
small yes of the mouse I know that one
thing a lot of people don't know about
you is that you are very big into
conspiracy here you go the noose was
gonna buckle it when did you first get
into exploring conspiracy theories I
think when I was like 15 I started to
look yeah too many question things and
no there's a lot of things that are
wrong and it's nothing that write on
internet but I like the fact that you
can you know research and and kind of
make your own idea you know what you
think it's true I think it's not I think
it's really interesting because
conspiracy theories you're just thoughts
that are out of the norm is something
you're genuinely passionate about like
you spend a lot of your time trying to
learn things that you're unsure of I
don't I don't like the term conspiracy
theory because it makes it look like
it's negative to actually question
things but I think it's a positive thing
if you're about to question things don't
believe that is true that because one
person tells you all because you've been
taught since your kid that this is true
what should we call them instead of
conspiracy theories what would you call
it just so we can have
turn questions question you believe in
questioning
I believe in questioning give me your
thoughts on aliens I'm gonna do
something else I almost think this is
one I can get behind
I believe that they're aliens I just
think statistically numbers wise it's
much more unlikely for us to be the only
people do you think they down earth
anymore I don't think there are aliens
on earth do you think they're aliens on
earth I think it's busted but complain
even know where we are
lady so if these aliens are on earth
what do they look like what are they
doing is it something like someone in
this room could be an alien yeah
probably comes down to you believe what
you want to believe and you ask yourself
what you want ask yourself if you just
want to believe the easy answer to make
you feel better like most people do then
it's fine do the aliens know that we
exist
you think my uh my best friend's an
idiot what do you ask me like I know you
can do your show without any mixed up
with an alien that be face what would
you ask an alien
she likes basketball she she was thank
you Dad the tail roots that's the best
question over them are you know what I
want to do when I get up here I just
want to yell
the other word is SWAT Lake let's yell
it swallow swallow
oh really yeah okay I'm 3-1 don't hang
me out to dry two three I would come out
here and yell every day I've been here
six years I've never thought about
coming yet it's a crazy Phoenix I don't
have long enough arms to do it you're
right the hair doesn't there we go
so had a great time take your damn
antenna will just tell you to watch it
and look we drew words in your house
[Music]
hello guys it is Taylor rooks thank you
so much for watching my show I take it
there but now you have to subscribe you
don't want to miss the next interview
and all the fun stuff we're doing on the
YouTube channel so hit that subscribe
button thanks see you guys soon